>> ALMOST ALL PEOPLE SAID THAT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM WOULD
NEVER PASS.
WE CAME TOGETHER AS A GROUP,
WORKED ACROSS PARTY LINES AND
GOT IT DONE.
>> I'M HUMBLED, THANKFUL.
JARED, THANK YOU FOR BEING
INSISTENT ABOUT GETTING THIS
BILL PASSED.
>> TWO MONTHS AGO, I WAS IN A
PRISON CELL.
NOW I'M IN A WHITE HOUSE.
THAT'S CONTINUING TO MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
>> Sean: THAT CELEBRATION JUST
HOURS AGO AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE BIPARTISAN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM JUST PASSED BY CONGRESS
IN DECEMBER.
IT WAS A PERSONAL MISSION FOR MY
NEXT GUEST.
TODAY I SAT DOWN WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S SON-IN-LAW, SENIOR
ADVISER JARED KUSHNER TO TALK
ABOUT THAT LAW, HIS REACTION TO
THE MUELLER REPORT AND MORE.
>> JARED, GREAT TO HAVE YOU WITH
US.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
YOU DON'T DO A LOT OF
INTERVIEWS.
>> IT'S MY PLEASURE.
>> Laura: YOU HAVE A BIG EVENT.
THE BIG CELEBRATION.
A BIPARTISAN CELEBRATION IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, WHICH IS GREAT.
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE ENOUGH OF
THEM.
WE'LL GET TO THAT.
IT'S A HISTORIC DAY IN MY WAYS.
WE HAVE TO GET TO SOME OF THE
NEWS OF THE DAY FIRST.
THE LEFT IS GOING CRAZY ABOUT
THIS SECURITY CLEARANCE ISSUE.
A WHISTLE BLOWER FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE HAS GIVEN A PRIVATE
INTERVIEW ON CAPITOL HILL TO
DEMOCRATS.
SHE SAYS 25 INDIVIDUALS WERE
ABLE TO LEAP FROG OVER THE
CAREER PEOPLE'S CONCERN ABOUT
SECURITY CLEARANCES AND THEY
RECEIVED SECURITY CLEARANCES IN
HER VIEW IMPROPERLY.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> WHAT I CAN SAY IS THAT OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS THAT I'VE
BEEN HERE, I'VE BEEN ACCUSED OF
ALL TYPES OF THINGS.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS HAVE TURNED
OUT TO BE FALSE.
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF CRAZY
ACCUSATIONS THAT WE COLLUDED
WITH RUSSIA.
I COMPLIED WITH THE
INVESTIGATIONS, THE SENATE, THE
HOUSE, SAT FOR 20 HOURS OF
INTERVIEWS.
WHEN I CAME TO WASHINGTON I HAD
A SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS CAREER,
EXTENSIVE HOLDINGS.
I DISCLOSED MY HOLDINGS TO THE
OFFICE OF GOVERNMENT ETHICS.
WHAT I DID TO THAT, THEY TOLD ME
WHAT TO DIVEST, WHAT TO KEEP.
>> Laura: SHE SAID THERE WERE
GRAVE CONCERNS.
SHE HAS GRAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
POTENTIAL NATIONAL SECURITY
IMPLICATIONS.
DO YOU POSE A GRAVE NATIONAL
SECURITY CONCERN TO THE COUNTRY,
JARED KUSHNER?
>> ANYMORE THE WHITE HOUSE.
I WORK WITH PHENOMENAL PEOPLE.
THE LAST TWO YEARS, THE
PRESIDENT HAS DONE A PHENOMENAL
JOB IDENTIFYING THE NATIONAL
SECURITY PRIORITIES.
I HOPE I PLAYED A GOOD PART IN
PUSHING THOSE OBJECTIVES
FORWARD.
BECAUSE OF THE PRESIDENT'S
LEADERSHIP, THE WORLD IS SAFER
TODAY.
>> Laura: YOU GET THE SENSE THAT
THE DEMOCRATS KEEP MOVING THE
GOAL POSTS?
IT STRIKES ME AS INTERESTING AS
THIS COMES OUT TODAY AS MUELLER
FIZZLES.
>> WHAT I LEARNED, THERE'S
PEOPLE IN AMERICA CARE ABOUT AND
WHAT PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA AND
WASHINGTON CARE ABOUT.
>> Laura: I READ ON WHAT CNN WAS
SAYING ABOUT IT AFTER IT PASSED.
IT WAS LIKE THEY COULDN'T
BELIEVE THAT DONALD TRUMP WOULD
DO SOMETHING THAT WOULD HAPPEN
DISADVANTAGED PEOPLE, PEOPLE
THAT MADE BIG MISTAKES, CRIMINAL
MISTAKES, AND IT'S ALMOST LIKE
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO BELIEVE IT
COULD HAVE HAPPENED.
DOES THAT DISAPOINT YOU?
EVEN WHEN SOMETHING THAT SHOULD
BE BIPARTISAN IS STILL VIEWED IN
A NEGATIVE LIGHT?
ODD.
>> WHEN HE WAS APPROACHED WITH
THIS ISSUE AND HE SAW HOW A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN PRISON DIDN'T HAVE
THE SKILL SET AND HAD SO MANY
OBSTACLES PREVENTING THEM GOT
BACK ON PATH, HE SAID YEAH,
LET'S INVEST THE RESOURCES TO
HELP THEM SUCCEED.
HE'S A VERY COMPETENT EXECUTIVE
AND SOMETHING THAT HE DID
BECAUSE HE HAS A BIG HEART.
>> Laura: HOW MUCH OF IT BECAUSE
OF YOUR DAD AND YOUR DAD WENT TO
PRISON, HE WAS CONVICTED, HE
SERVED TIME.
WHAT DOES HE SAY ABOUT THESE
KINDS OF ISSUES WITH YOU?
>> THAT WAS A BIG PART.
THAT IS WHY I WAS EXPOSED TO THE
ISSUE.
HAD I JUST COME IN AS A
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE HEARING FROM
THE TOP DOWN AND WHAT A GREAT
JOB THEY WERE DOING, I PROBABLY
WOULD HAVE BELIEVE THAT.
SO MUCH MORE WE CAN BE DOING.
MY EXPERIENCE WITH MY FAMILY'S
SITUATION IS I MET A LOT OF
DIFFERENT FAMILIES A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT A LOT OF THEM ARE
GOOD PEOPLE.
THEY MADE A MISTAKE.
THE TOLL THAT IT WEIGHED ON THEM
AND THEIR FAMILIES
DISPROPORTIONATE.
>> Laura: WHAT IS THE
PRESIDENT'S THINKING ON THE
BORDER CLOSING?
HE IS SENT OUT A LOT OF TWEETS
ABOUT CLOSING THE BORDER.
WHERE IS HE ON THAT?
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS
MADE INCREASED AWARENESS TO THE
ISSUE.
HE'S WEIGHING ALL OPTIONS, WHICH
IS --
>> Laura: PRESSURING MEXICO.
IS THIS TO PRESENTATION SURE
MEXICO?
>> NO.
ONE OF THE THINGS I LIKE ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT, WHEN THERE'S A
PROBLEM, HE MAKES PEOPLE
CONFRONT IT.
HE'S CREATIVE ABOUT WAYS TO FIND
A SOLUTION.
>> Laura: ARE YOU GOING TO GET
THE USTA THROUGH CONGRESS?
>> TO CRAFT A DEAL, I HAVE TO
GIVE A LOT OF CREDIT TO
PRESIDENT TO NEGOTIATE THE DEAL.
I HAVE TO GIVE A LOT OF CREDIT
TO AMBASSADOR LIGHTHIZER.
HE NEGOTIATED THE DEAL AND
ARCHITECTING WHAT KIND OF DEAL
HE THOUGHT WOULD APPEAL TO THE
CONSTITUENTS.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING WITH THE DEAL
IS IT'S SOMETHING THAT IS A
WORLD CLASS TRADE AGREEMENT,
GREAT FOR FARMERS AND INDUSTRY
AND GREAT FOR TECHNOLOGY.
IT'S ALL OF THESE THINGS THAT
WILL ALLOW AMERICA TO BE
INDEPENDENT.
>> Laura: WE HAVE THE SOUND BITE
ON MSNBC, A REPORTER THERE.
THIS IS WHAT HE JUST SAID LAST
COUPLE DAYS ABOUT THE USMCA.
LET'S WATCH.
>> TALKING ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS INABILITY TO SEE
HUMANITY.
HE'S VERY EASILY ABLE TO SEE THE
ECONOMICS OF STORIES LIKE THIS
ONE.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAS HAPPENED
WITH THE U.S. MEXICO CANADA
TRADE DEAL, IT'S FALLING APART.
THE PRESIDENT'S TWITTER FEED AS
A GUIDE HERE.
THAT MAY WELL BE WHAT SPURRED
THE PRESIDENT TO MAKE THIS
THREAT.
>> Laura: HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
CLOSING THE BORDER THERE.
HE BROUGHT UP THE CLOSE THE
BORDER ISSUE BECAUSE THE USMCA
IS "FALLING APART."
IS THERE ANY TRUTH TO THAT?
>> NO.
THE FUTURE THAT I LOVE, WE BUILT
IN A 16-YEAR SUNSET.
IF YOU HAVE A GREAT ASSET, WE
DON'T WANT TO SELL IT.
WHAT WE TO HERE, WE REALLY LEASE
OUR MARKET ACCESS.
WE DO THAT EVERY 6 YEARS, HAVE A
FAIR MARKET VALUE RENEWAL TO
REBALANCE.
>> Laura: YOU WERE INSTRUMENTAL
IN THE PRESIDENT'S RUN IN 2016.
WHAT DO YOU SEE IN THIS DEMOCRAT
FIELD?
ANY INTERESTING CHARACTERS, SOME
MORE THAN OTHERS THAT YOU'D LIKE
TO RUN AGAINST?
>> WE LOOKED AT 2020.
WE FIGURING OUT HOW DO WE KEEP
BUILDING THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE.
THE PRESIDENT WILL HAVE A
FABULOUS CAMPAIGN AND HE HAS THE
COUNTRY ON THE RIGHT TRACK.
A LOT OF THE DIFFERENT POLICIES
I SEE, A LOT OF THESE DEMOCRATS
ADVOCATING FOR OR OFFERING, I
DON'T THINK THAT'S WHERE THE
COUNTRY IS.
>> Laura: SOCIALISM.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S WHERE
THE COUNTRY IS.
ONE STATISTIC THAT I FOUND
PLEASING, MORE OF THE -- IN
FLORIDA THEY PASSED ALLOW WHERE
FORMER FELONS CAN VOTE.
WE'VE HAD MORE EX-FELONS
REGISTER AS REPUBLICANS THAN
DEMOCRATS.
>> Laura: WHOA.
YOU'VE HAD MORE EX-FELONS
REGISTER AS EX-FELONS THAN
DEMOCRATS?
>> THAT'S THE DAY THAT I'VE